Australia's prime minister has urged
voters to support the creation of an
Aboriginal voice in law making Anthony
albinism made the play Messi revealed
the wording of a referendum question and
the issue Australians will vote on it
later this year if it passes it's going
to set up a panel to advise Parliament
on issues that impact the lives of
Aboriginal people if it's successful the
vote would mean an amendment to the
Constitution
this is a modest request
I say to you
I said to Australia don't miss it
don't miss it
so I want this done for indigenous
Australians but I want it done for all
Australians we will feel better about
ourselves
if we get this done
we'll just feel better
and you know what I've said this and
this has been contested
but the truth is
that Australia will be seen as a better
Nation as well by the rest of the world
that's just a fact
Sarah Clark joining us now from Brisbane
with more um Anthony Albany is there
choking up when he was making those
statements give us more detail about the
final wording and what it actually means
well it is a significant Milestone on
Thursday in this historic March towards
constitutional change and constitutional
recognition of the First Nations people
in Australia and a voice giving them a
voice in Parliament as we just heard the
Prime Minister he was very emotional he
put out an emotional plea when he
released this proposed final wording for
the referendum he choked up when he
delivered this now I should note the
exact wording is is for the referendum
will go to the Australian people we
believe in October this year is a
proposed law to alter the Constitution
to recognize the first people of
Australia by establishing an Aboriginal
and Torres Strait Islander voice do you
approve of this proposed alteration now
if Australia votes yes uh then that
wording will be included in the
Constitutional as we mentioned an
advisory body would be set up and that
advisory body would make representations
uh to the executive government but as
well it would make a voice to Federal
Parliament now behind the scenes here or
certainly from Australian perspective
there's been months of debates about
this proposed wording and this voice in
federal Parliament and huge discussion
about the exact wording and the wording
that was released today and approved by
cabinet has been tweaked uh from the
earlier wording released by the Prime
Minister and the Constitutional analysts
say uh it was a subtle but significant
change but the tweak uh or the tweaked
wording was designed to win over some of
those critics from what you're saying I
mean with the amount of preparation
that's been done for this and the amount
of research that's been done and as if
as you see it's just a subtle tweak one
would assume that this is going to have
a fairly smooth passage but what has
been the reaction
well the conservative opposition that
being the opposition led by the liberal
Peter Dutton who's the opposition leader
he has long asked for more detail he
said he doesn't want Australia to go to
a referendum when there's not enough
detail about not just the voice but also
the advisory body and that's for the
national party which is also the
conservatives uh they've questioned
whether or not they believe or we need
another level of bureaucracy at a
federal level but the new wording does
make it more specific it says The Voice
May make representations to Parliament
and executive government as opposed to
just to the executive government as for
the indigenous reaction there's also
been a lot of debate from the indigenous
Community we've had the high profile
First Nations people flanks the Prime
Minister today uh in in Parliament on
Thursday they believe that this is a key
step and and crucial to repairing the
relationship between the indigenous and
non-indigenous Australians they also
said that the hearts and Minds can be
cleared now of the oppression uh and The
Shame of the past uh if we do go uh to
the referendum and if this referendum
does get up but we still have a long way
to go this is a historic step but we
expect the debate to go on and we do
believe that this proposed wording
that's been approved by cabinet will go
through Federal Parliament for the next
stage of debate next week Sarah thank
you very much indeed that's Sarah Clark
talking to us from Brisbane